Prof: You remember,
when I was talking about
Europe, we discussed the fact
that during marriage Europeans
just had babies,
in a sense willy-nilly,
but we also said it was nowhere
near the maximum that humans are
capable of,
but we thought it was sort of
cultural constraints,
late marriage,
and stuff like that.
Now we come to China in which
the birth rate within marriage
was quite a bit lower and I
introduced the question of
whether this was voluntary in
the sense of individually
decided,
an individual decides what they
want and acts on it,
or was this low birth rate due
to cultural constraints in a
crowded household with maybe the
grandmother sleeping beneath
you.
There's no opportunity,
if the cultural rules say you
can't be friends with your wife,
there may be a reduction in
passion,
and the conclusion that I gave
you was that this didn't seem to
be an individual decision kind
of thing but a cultural kind of
thing.
It's a little bit out of place
but I just can't--
I love this data so much,
it's so very striking as an
example of people that are not
individually voluntarily
controlling their fertility.
How would you tell if someone
is?
--You have a big huge
population, you can't interview
all of them,
maybe it's a dead population,
old, how do you tell whether
they're making individual
decisions?
Well you have--one of the ways
of doing it is to consider
individual events in their lives
that you think,
under any reasonable idea of
what it is to be a human,
would affect their fertility.
One of those events is the
death of a child.
There's many--I mean I think
you all would naturally say,
if you want a certain number of
children you're going to control
consciously--
if your children die,
you're going to try harder to
have more,
you're going to try longer.
Here is a Chinese population
from 1982, so we're talking
about just at the time when the
one child policy is starting.
These are women who have
finished their childbearing by
1982, so it's the generation
exactly prior to the one-child
policy.
It gives you a lot of data but
look over here,
it says what happened to the
first four children,
and it gives you two cases:
all the children died or all
survived.
There's a lot of intermediate
cases which are not shown in
this particular graph and it's
spread out by age to seeing if
there some sort of age effect.
Here is the mother's age at
last birth, so if all of them
survived--if all of them died
you would think the mother would
really want to have more.
She stops giving birth at age
38.7.
If they all survived,
1/10th of a year,
she stops giving birth 1/10th
of a year earlier,
one month earlier.
Same, a little bit older group
you have 0.4 year,
maybe four months later,
and here's 0.1 months again for
women who are 20--their age at
first birth.
I'm sorry; the age at which
they stop depends on the age at
which they start to a large
degree.
The numbers of this way are
different because they started
at different ages,
but there's no difference
within an age group depending on
whether all four children died
or all four children survived.
That's just--to me that's an
amazing set of statistics that
apparently the continuation,
the attempt to have as many
children as possible just does
not depend on that event.
Here's another example of this,
this is--
as was discussed in most of
Asia, a lot of the world,
and especially China,
they need males,
sons are much preferred over
daughters.
Here's a very nicely displayed
set of data saying how many sons
have you had,
how many daughters?
Here's--that have had no son or
no daughter, and the question is
how many of them proceed?
These numbers show the fraction
that proceeds to have the first
birth.
When they get married and they
have no children,
neither a son nor a daughter
0.958--I'm sorry they have a son
first;
they have one son or one
daughter.
Those that have a son 95.8% of
them proceed to have a second
child and that can be either a
boy or a girl.
If their first child is a
daughter 96.8% proceed,
so you don't have to look up
here and the details aren't
important,
but look at for instance those
that have seven sons in a row,
and 72%, 72.5% of them proceed
to get pregnant again.
Here's seven daughters in a
row, they want the sons,
and they may not want
daughters, 76%,
a 3.5% difference,
almost no difference in their
life.
Again, how many of them,
after having seven sons,
you presume that's enough sons,
whereas seven daughters they
would be desperate to have more
but there's a very small--
a 3% difference between the
fraction of them that proceed.
You can also see the numbers
are very high;
those that have had seven
children already,
76% proceed to have another
birth.
They just keep going,
and whether they have all
daughters in a row,
or all sons in a row,
makes very little difference.
Finally at eight there is--it
is a 10%--
less than, yes,
a 10% difference,
but whether that's--
that doesn't fit with the rest
of the graph but it's still very
small difference.
Here's the last graph of this
nature.
This is again the age at the
mother's last birth,
and again, it's the same kind
of graph.
Those that have had eight
daughters in a row versus those
that have eight sons in a row,
and you think,
in a son desiring culture,
if they were controlling their
fertility in any individualistic
way,
that the ones with a lot of
sons would say,
okay enough and the ones with a
lot of daughters would be
desperate to finally have a son.
Look at the difference,
the age of 41.4,
if they have eight sons in a
row and the age 41.7,
again 3/10ths of a year.
They try just a little bit
longer, three months longer.
Basically I think what this
data is telling you is that
people are,
for sure, not responding to the
most important fertility events
in their life,
either the sex composition of
their children or the death of
the children;
they're just having children.
Not at an enormous rate because
of the cultural things that
everybody is behaving under,
not with respect to their
individual experiences and
desires.
This is the context into which
the one-child--
first the Wan,
Xi, Shao, the later,
longer, fewer policy drops in
and then ten years later the
one-child policy,
so it gives you an
amazing--here's a population
that's just finished
childbearing when the policy
starts and there's apparently no
thought whatsoever of
individually controlling
fertility.
All of a sudden the government
tells you,
hey you got to have fewer
children,
and I showed you the rate of
fall, the rate of fall during
the 1970s was just fantastic.
Then after that fall,
again as I told you last time,
to control momentum,
they instituted the one-child
policy and the number of births
levels off.
Why does the number of births
level off?
This is again the fertility
drop, this is the longer,
later, fewer policy in the
1970s and that's where you get
the big drop;
1980 the one-child policy,
you don't get any further
drops.
That was a sign of--well,
an incompetent government,
an incompetently carried out
fertility policy.
It turns out that one arm of
the government was doing
something to the opposite effect
of another arm of the
government.
Here the Chinese were--for
women's rights issues and to
control--
somewhat control the
population--they were
encouraging later marriage,
they didn't want girls married
at 13,
14,15 and so forth.
It had been very successful,
the revolution is out here,
and the age of marriage is
already up to 19.5 or so by 1965
and they're being very
successful and the age of
marriage keeps going up until it
reaches a quite respectable 23,
that's older than basically all
of you are--
most of you, not all of you.
It reaches a peak there.
Then what does the government
do?
It says well we're doing great,
we're now very worried,
this is the year where they
introduced the one-child policy,
we want this to continue on up.
They don't have good
demographic statistics and they
don't know this data,
they don't actually know what
age people are actually marrying
at,
so they have an official age
which was actually above this
and they--
I'm sorry, they raised that age
to prevent more marriages but
since people were below that
what happened was--
let's see I'm getting this
backwards.
They--anyway the result of a
policy they had an opposite
result,
that the result of instituting
a new policy intending to raise
marriage age reduced marriage
age instead.
Then you see when they
introduce the one-child policy
the mean age of marriage goes
down and it goes down quite
significantly.
The one-child policy saying you
should have fewer children is
working oppositely to a new
policy that actually reduces the
age at marriage and increases
the .
The result is,
this is the number of new
marriages,
first marriages,
and there's a rise here,
then there's kind of dipsy
doodles,
and then, just at the time of
the one-child policy,
the number of new marriages
goes crazy.
This big rise in the number of
marriages,
and remember 98% of Chinese
women, when the get married,
get pregnant right away,
so the next year they had
babies,
this counteracts basically all
of the effect of the one-child
policy.
That's one branch of government
making one set of laws,
not having the data and not
being in accord with what
another set of government is
doing.
In fact the one-child policy--I
don't want to leave you with
impression that the one-child
policy had no effect but you
have to do different statistics.
Remember the total fertility
rate takes all the women that
are in an age group,
whether they're married or not,
and ask how many children
they're having.
Well when you have a big change
in the fraction of women married
then you have to use a different
statistic.
When the age of marriage
changes, as it did in China at
that time,
you have to now look at a new
statistic called the parity
progression ratio which is very
much like those triangle graphs
that I showed you.
This says--this black line is
how many proceed from having no
children to having one child,
so the fraction of women--and
this is in the 95% range or
something.
Basically all the Chinese
women, at this time when they
get married, give birth to their
first child.
Now the next number is those
that already have one child,
what fraction of them proceed
to have two children?
The answer is,
before this policy,
even more than the one,
98% of women that already have
one child proceed to have a
second child and that may be
that in this group are fairly--
are sterile women or sterile
men and so that may be the
difference between here,
but we don't have that data.
Again, this is very,
very high and then the other
numbers, those that have two
children how many go to three?
Those that have three children
how many go to four or more and
so forth and we don't have data
before this.
You can see that the first
child is uninterrupted;
the Wan, Xi,
Shao, the later,
longer, fewer policy and the
one-child policy does not
interrupt the first birth.
That goes on as normal which is
what is expected,
but going to a second child now
at the time of the introduction
of the one-child policy,
this crashes as does later
births.
The one-child policy did have
an effect if you look at those
already married,
but the two different policies,
one lowering the age of
marriage counteracts the effect
and for a number of years the
fertility rate stays constant.
We've just had some visitors,
let me show what I was talking
about.
This is the birthrate in China,
what's called the total
fertility rate,
and here is 1970 when the
later, longer,
fewer policy was introduced and
it was the decade of the 1970s
where the fertility rate in
China fell.
In 1979/1980 the one-child
policy is introduced and for
about a decade or so the
birthrate does not decrease
under that.
We have some guests apparently.
What was happening was that in
the cities,
as I mentioned,
there was a very significant
birth drop in the 1960s,
even before the government
was--then in the 1970s,
during Wan, Xi,
Shao, the city populations went
down to below fertility level.
In the countryside's,
even though there was a big
drop in the 1970s,
it wasn't anything like it was
in the cities.
As you heard from Qing who
talked about her family's
experience,
in the cities there were many
people that worked for the
government,
and so were under tight
government control.
Many of them worked in
government owned factories so
were under tight government
control,
and in general,
in cities there is much more
ability to control the people.
However, at that time,
80% of Chinese people lived in
villages.
It was still a very rural
country and there the story is
different.
Among other things,
in many villages,
all the people are related,
they're all relatives.
So, the professor who's got the
next lab to mine is named Zhong
and in his village everybody is
a Zhong, and they're all
related.
If people don't believe in a
policy,
they don't want to obey the
government and everybody is
related,
your uncle second removed can't
really enforce a policy on you
if you're a relative,
especially in a culture where
kinship means so much and the
relationship between relatives
means so much.
The one-child policy was much,
much less successful in the
countryside.
Similarly, the cities were
beginning to have excess jobs
and people were streaming out of
the countryside,
also because of the population
growth there was no land left,
so they were streaming out of
the countryside going into the
cities,
they didn't have legal living
permits.
They have a system where you
document where you live and you
have to stay there and they were
not allowed officially to come
into the cities,
but of course they did,
and so the government didn't
know where they were and
basically had no control over
them and so they were very hard
to control.
Even though among--Then another
thing that happens,
again just at this time,
is that previously everybody--
the peasants had been in
communes and I talked about them
last time,
several thousand families in
one big farm,
and under again,
strict control of the
government.
Then with the Great Leap
Forward they realized the
commune system has failed and
the land goes back to the
people,
they break up the communes and
people get their own plot of
land.
They don't own it in our sense
but they have the rights to work
on that plot of land.
Well they started growing their
own food, private markets for
food grow up,
and the people are not getting
everything they need from the
government.
If they really oppose some
government policy then they can
tell the government 'bye-bye,' I
don't need anything from you,
I'm now an independent farmer
and I'll do what I want.
The change to a market economy,
that changed to more economic
freedom for the individuals,
led to all kinds of personal
freedom and led to the ability
to say no to the government.
At the time,
in the press,
there were all kinds of
examples of what was going on,
and for instance here's one
article from 1980 again--
I'm sorry this is 2000.
The one-child policy has been
in effect for 20 years,
"No one can accuse Huo
Suifa of not knowing what he
wanted.
The 47-year-old farmer dreamed
of having a son.
After seven daughters he
finally got a male heir in 1989.
Ho named him Gaifeng,
or 'change-in-the-weather,' and
then he stopped having
children,"
so seven daughters and a son,
so this person--most--almost
all of that time must have been
under the one-child policy;
eight children.
He says, "It wasn't easy
to have all these children,
but it wasn't hard
either,"
the farmer said.
"If things became tough in
our village,
if there was a campaign to
enforce the rule in their
village"
and China has these political
campaigns to get people to
change their behavior quite
routinely at this time,
"Well my wife just went to
another township to have the
child."
What's the other side of the
coin is this Huo now has a wife
and eight children to support,
and how much land does he have?
One-third of an acre for eight,
nine, ten people;
this is not a good economic
system, exactly why the
one-child policy was instituted.
An American misconception,
fed by our press,
is that China's government is
very monolithic.
The chairman in Peking or some
bureaucrat says this is the
rule, this is law,
spells it out,
everybody has to obey this law.
Isn't the case;
there's whole books now on how
China is actually ruled,
and the story is that the
government almost gives a
slogan,
it's a one-child policy,
or they sometimes call it the
only child policy,
is not a set of rules it's kind
of almost a slogan.
Then it goes down to the
provinces, and each province has
to determine in accord with
local conditions as which is the
official way of stating it.
Then each province gives it
down to the prefectures and the
same thing,
it's interpreted by
local--under local conditions
and then it goes down to the
villages where it's completely
changed.
There's no--absolutely no
uniformity from village to
village.
What that resulted in was the
policy was never able to be
consistently put into practice.
The statistics give you the
answer to that.
The total fertility rate during
this initial period of
enforcement of the one-child
policy never fell below two,
so the policy was one child,
but it never fell below two
children.
In the rural areas it never
fell below 2.5.
As you saw a couple of lectures
ago,
Qing showed you the one child
certificate where the couple
promises,
it's just a promise,
this doesn't say you've done it
and this is just--
even to promise that you're
only going to have one child,
and less than 20% of married
couples ever signed onto even
that promise of having one
child,
which was telling the
government, no we're not going
to comply with this policy.
Throughout the 1980s,
which again was when the policy
was strictly enforced,
nearly half of all the births
were second,
third, or higher order births.
Eighty percent of China's
children had brothers or
sisters,
or both, many had both and only
1/5th of the 300 million
children under age 14 were from
single child families.
In 1986, again after the
first--Question?
Student:  Would you say
this is a result of inconsistent
applications of the one-child
policy or a reflection of the
fact that the one-child policy
was never (inaudible) one child
and not in that urban area?
Prof: Both,
at this time initially it was
supposed to be one child for all
except minority people,
so a very small part of the
population.
I'll tell you in a minute
that--because of popular
resistance they immediately
loosened it up,
so the main thing which you're
probably referring to is that
rather soon they said peasants--
the city people had already had
their fertility drop.
Many of them were not very
interested in having more than
one child.
It was not a huge issue for you;
one of your readings discusses
that.
In the countryside the peasants
still wanted,
certainly a son,
more children,
so the policy was changed
rather rapidly so that if you--
if your first child is a
daughter you can have another
one and try for a boy,
but two is the limit and of
course two was not--
even that was not always
observed.
Remember I told you last time
that the goal when the Chinese
population crossed a billion,
or looked like it was very
close to crossing a billion,
and the government sort of
desperately wanted to keep the
population below 1.2 billion in
the year 2000 they didn't make
it,
the population was 1.3 billion.
They missed by a 100 million
and now it's considerably over
that and the population is still
growing.
Because of population momentum,
again the age structure of
China,
China's population is expected
to grow by another 150 million
people by 2025,
so even though they've worked
so hard and suffered so much
under these various policies to
restrict fertility,
they're still going to increase
from now,
from 2008 to 2025 by half the
total population of the United
States.
Again, comparable to a
calculation I gave earlier,
Hu Jintao, who was president of
China recently says,
the party plans to quadruple
economic output per capita in
that time.
This was before the economic
crash that has just happened.
He wanted to quadruple the per
capita income,
which would still bring China
up only to a low European level
perhaps.
With a 1.3 billion population,
and you're quadrupling it,
that's equal to 5.2 billion and
the whole population of the
earth is only 6.3,
so you're talking about China's
economic and population growth
alone almost doubling the
world's economic activity and
therefore something like
doubling the economic drain on
it.
China's TFR now,
after this period of stability
and after the marriage thing got
settled it has drifted down
slowly as almost all of the
world has.
It's now 1.6,
it's still nowhere near one
child per family,
its 1.6 now,
but that will eventually reduce
the size of the Chinese
population if it is maintained.
What you should keep in mind
is, this was the Chinese route
to lower population.
I described to you the
population that they started
with that was not paying any
attention to individual desires
in fertility and they brought it
down by strong government
policy,
good amount of coercion and so
forth.
The Chinese populations around
other parts of East Asia have
lowered their birth rate even
more, or I should say they
started lower;
they reached an even lower
level.
China is 1.6 as I told you;
the Chinese population of
Singapore is 1.4 children per
women.
The Japanese,
who are not Chinese obviously,
1.3;
Taiwan 1.1;
South Korea,
again not Chinese,
1.3;
Hong Kong 1.0 and Macau 1.0.
None of these places were under
the one-child policy.
Actually I'm not sure about
Macau, but all the others are
not under the one child policy,
and they have a lower birth
rate than the Chinese policy,
and we'll have to discuss in a
later lecture why this should be
so.
I'm going to finish up talking
specifically about China to
mention a little bit about
economic globalization which
you're all aware of.
Because of globalization the
U.S.
and China are joined at the
hip.
For both our economies to
succeed, we have to buy a lot of
Chinese stuff,
they have to buy our bonds,
they keep their people employed
by shipping us stuff,
and we send them green paper
back.
The economics of this is quite
crazy altogether because they
can never use--
what's interesting is they
basically can never use the
money that we send them.
That if--they have a trillion
dollars or so in U.S.
bonds and if they ever try to
sell them the value of the
dollar goes to zero and they
have to sell them for nothing.
That's a separate story,
it's crazy.
Lot of causes--reasons for
globalization.
Number one is shipping costs,
the whole idea of the shipping
when it went to containers,
the cost of shipping something
from China to the West Coast of
America dropped drastically.
Ships carry an awful lot,
the water floats them across,
and they just have to--the only
energy that's used is to get
over the friction of the water
that they go through.
Even many years ago I was in
Bolivia discussing with an AID
guy, Bolivia is very poor,
what can they do?
Well they have the mountains
but then they have a jungle
sloping down to the Amazon where
they could grow rice,
very good agricultural land,
and why can't they give that to
Lima or to La Paz,
Lima and Peru where they're
importing rice.
The problem was that the
Chinese can grow it in the
Yangtze Valley,
float it down the river to
Shanghai,
put it on a boat,
and ship it and deliver it to
Callao,
Lima's port,
cheaper than the Bolivians who
are right next door to Peru can
truck it over --
the Andes sort of go up and
down and up again--
and down again and they have to
ship it--
to get to the coast they have
to ship it over two peaks of
mountains on lousy roads,
and trucking is just very
inefficient.
It's cheaper to get the thing
from 15,000 miles away up in
Sichuan than to get it next door
from the Amazon slopes of
Bolivia,
so shipping costs is very
important.
For white collar jobs it's
telecommunication.
Now--we used to say let's let
the low,
the cheap labor manufacturing
jobs go to China but now China
and India we're in--
its immediate contact by
telecommunications so the white
collar jobs are going there.
The engineering is going to
India, the accounting is going
to India, the call centers are
going to India,
and other jobs are going to
China.
This--what happens to
population I think,
in the long term view,
and long terms means 25 or 50
years,
I'm not talking 1000 years,
probably the one most important
thing which will determine the
future of the U.S.
economy is what happens to
population in China and India,
and you can include Indonesia
and the rest of Asia.
As long as they have an
incredible number of people
willing to work for incredibly--
needing to work for incredibly
low wages,
we can't compete with them.
There is no economic reason why
an American should earn $40 a
day or something like that,
plus benefits,
and that's a low wage for an
American.
Whereas, a third of China the
per capita income is about $1 a
day for the lowest third of
China and that means the worker
makes $2 or $3 a day.
There's no way that we can
earn, without benefits,
that we can earn $40 or $80
depending on what you calculate
and other people in the other
world are earning $3,
so jobs are going to continue
to go to China;
not only from the United States.
They are leaving Mexico.
I told you the story in
Thailand, the jewelry business
in Thailand that moved to China,
that there's just this vast,
vast sea of people who are
desperate to work for basically
$2 a day.
A further thing happening,
there are now a few 100 million
people floating around the
cities,
migrant laborers trying to get
jobs,
and now with the current
economic climate,
being thrown out of jobs,
but Chinese agriculture is
incredibly inefficient.
As I told you,
the average farm size there is
0.1 acre in China and that's
just economically unsustainable.
The average farm size in the
world is--in Japan is 400 acres
I think.
No, I'm sorry in the world 400,
in the U.S.,
an economic U.S.
farm is like thousands of acres
of big farms.
We're talking about that,
eventually China is going to
have to compete in the
agricultural world on an even
footing with the rest of the
world,
which means their farms are
going to have to combine.
That's already happening.
People are voluntarily sort of
pooling their land,
having big things--enough of
the land to be--
to make it worth them to buy a
tractor and so forth,
so this economic
rationalization of agriculture
is happening.
Think of the numbers there,
you have 800 million peasants
with 0.1 acre each.
When you combine it even to 100
acre farm, which is still a
small farm worldwide that means
you combined 1000 farms into
one.
In the modern world 100 acres
is probably farmed by one or two
people,
so you go from 1000 families
living on 0.1 acre each to maybe
two families living on 100 acres
of a combined farm.
That means that something like
99% of the population of the
countryside has to get jobs
somewhere else.
If you have 800 million
peasants, almost 800 million new
people are waiting for these
economic changes to come onto
the modern job market,
and so there are a vast number
of people waiting,
that are now competing with us
and every other industrial
advanced country,
and who will continue to
compete with us.
The Chinese government is well
aware, of course,
of all this stuff.
In October last year,
previously I--
they don't really own their
land and they still don't,
but they what they call a land
reform and the plan allows
farmers for the first time to
lease or transfer their land use
rights to someone else.
Basically the Chinese are now
allowed to sell their farm,
which will ease--now they have
to have very complicated
collective arrangements where
everybody is sort of still
there,
but once you can basically sell
or alienate your land in some
way,
than you can totally leave the
land and go into the cities.
The government has started
encouraging this kind of push.
What they'll do now,
with the economic collapse,
I don't know.
It's--we have a long way to go
before the population issue in
China is settled and our fate
and all of the developed world
depends very much on what
happens in China.
Just to finish,
the Chinese have--the
achievement of China is just
mind boggling.
that In a half a century they
took people from an extremely
poor country,
devastated by over 100 years of
war,
and now it's becoming one of
the first ranked countries in
the world.
Before this all started,
no one would have thought this
was possible.
If you can read the literature
of that time,
China was hopeless.
With respect to fertility,
which you'll see is a very
important part of the whole
story of economic success,
their decline,
the rapidity of their decline
to get a country like China to
drop its fertility in ten years
is just an amazing achievement;
just incredible.
Now, we want to get onto this
next question that a student
asked last time.
When I was saying the
Chinese--remember the Chinese
started this population thing
for economic reasons.
They said--our economy is going
along,
we're increasing,
like I said,
agricultural production what
was it 2.5% a year,
which was very good -- but
population is growing 2.3% a
year,
so we're not helping the people.
It was very overtly stated that
the one-child policy was to
improve China's economy.
They wanted to improve the
standard of living of the
people.
At the time,
when they started this policy,
the standard of living in China
was very low,
and I don't have to tell you
that.
Healthcare was very--was
certainly better than it had
been but still a very low level.
Education was not widely
available below the very early
primary grades in China.
Basically, as the Chinese
perceived it themselves,
and as they talked about it
quite a bit, their children were
growing up unhealthy and
uneducated.
When the Chinese talk about
economic development,
it's not only manufacturing
more stuff which they basically
are not too interested in,
they ship it to America.
They were primarily interested
in what they called the quality
of the people.
They thought their population
was not of the quality that they
wanted, and quality means health
and education.
They wanted--their children
were growing up not healthy and
not educated,
and they like everyone in the
world,
realizes that uneducated,
sick children,
and sick adults don't--are not
very productive.
Western economists,
for a long time,
considered capitalist--physical
capital your factories and
machines that you have and the
idea of human-capital is fairly
recent and has now come
massively into vogue in the
West.
That one of the most important
determinants of the wealth of a
country,
why is one country rich and one
country poor is not resources,
is not your physical capital
base, but your human capital
base.
Partly we've learned that from
the Chinese.
I mean we learned it ourselves
but also the Chinese examples
were very good example of this.
Just to give you an example of
what happens when people don't
have education,
in this particular case
biological education,
is a story from again the year
2000--
again not that many years back.
This is from Du who was a local
official in a small village.
He said, "One day there
were hundreds of people lined up
at the entrance of our village,
I thought it must be a
vegetable market or a movie
coming in.
It turned out to be blood
selling.
I felt so terrified because
there was no sterilization
equipment at all."
This village official had some
education, he understood about
sterilization and he had seen
these blood campaigns before,
no sterilization.
"Villagers just tell the
traffickers their blood type,
if they know it,
if not they make it up.
The villagers just tell the
traffickers their blood type and
then lie die on the ground to
offer blood."
What is the result of this?
A vast AIDS epidemic in these
rural villages that were doing
this,
because they use the same
needle to repeatedly take blood
from person after person,
they line up on the ground and
they stick one needle,
take the blood.
Needles are so expensive,
the apparatus for collecting it
is expensive,
and so they reuse the same
needle.
Of course when you use the same
needle from person to person the
odds are if one person gets it
the next ones are going to get
it,
but actually the transmission
rate by blood to blood contact
by a needle is something like 1
in 200,
it's not terribly efficient.
What do they do with the blood?
They collect blood from
everybody, then instead of
keeping it individually,
which is expensive,
they dump it into a big vat,
they pool it,
they take it to the city,
they extract the components
that they want which is the
gamma globulin,
the clotting factor,
and a few other components and
then they have a lot of blood
left.
What do they do?
They go back to the village and
re-inject the blood,
the remaining blood into the
people.
Now you don't just have a
needle stick,
you've got a pint of someone
else--of a mixed blood of
everyone in the village going
into your veins,
and now for sure if anyone in
the village has AIDS you're
going to be infected with it.
Du continued,
"The villagers become
crazy about selling blood
because they are so poor and
life is so hard.
Many had built their houses by
selling blood.
Some will even bribe
traffickers to be able to sell
more than once a day."
The traffickers are interested
in giving them back blood
because then they'll make more
blood,
they can sell more blood again,
but the people want to sell
more than a pint in each day,
so they kind of lie and fake
because they're so poor.
The officials estimate
something like 600,000 HIV
cases, that's probably nowhere
near correct.
The blood collections,
starting in the 1990s,
were protected by corrupt
officials.
This was of course against
public policy,
but it may have infected a
million people,
this blood selling in Henan
Province,
especially and virtually all of
them poor peasants who sold the
blood to make money.
That gives you an idea again of
the status of education of the
population and why human capital
is so very important,
because you're collecting blood
to sell to hospitals,
which will improve the health
of presumably of some people who
receive the blood,
but not if they get AIDS.
While you're helping a few
people with transfusions you're
infecting millions of people
with AIDS so you're making
things totally worse.
Does cutting your
population--so China had the
idea, not alone,
that if they reduce their
population growth rate their
economy will improve.
Is this true?
Most economists,
at the time,
would certainly have said no.
That's a Malthusian idea that
population--
that economic development is
limited by population growth and
people thought that the
industrial revolution had sort
of gotten rid of Malthus,
Malthus was irrelevant.
Marx, as I mentioned last time,
hated Malthus.
Marx was totally opposed and so
a lot of the world's opinion was
that no, population growth was
not detrimental to the economy.
In fact, they believed that
population growth was good for
an economy because it increased
the market,
and everybody wants to increase
and you can get efficiencies of
scale for all kinds of reasons,
a growing population was
considered to be a wonderful
thing.
Businessmen,
especially in the capitalist
economies,
love population growth because
the population of the United
States,
for instance,
is now growing at 1% a year,
which is less than it had been,
it had been 1.5% or so.
The economic growth rate is
about 3%, at best in a very good
year, in a good year it's 3%.
Population growth at 1% or
1.5%, if your total economy is
growing at 2% or 3%,
population growth is half the
increase in gross national
product and that means it's half
of company profits.
When you have General Motors,
it was counting every year on
population growing and being
able to sell more automobiles.
That was basically the idea
that population growth was not a
bad thing.
In 1958 two American
demographer economists had a
different idea.
They looked at the developing
countries, which had enormous
population and very high growth
rates and they weren't doing so
well.
What's with this theory?
They should be doing
wonderfully, they should be
improving tremendously,
and they came up with a
different understanding of the
relationship between population
and economics.
This is based on some very
simply economics.
That economic development
requires investment.
If you want to produce
something you've got to build a
factory and that takes money.
Where does that money come from?
That comes from someone else
saving.
Someone earns some money,
by his labor or by whatever,
earns some money;
he can either spend that right
away or he can put it in the
bank and then the bank will
invest it for him,
or he can put it into stocks or
something like that.
Investment in a country,
within some kind of economy,
investment requires savings.
One person has to save so
another can spend it as an
investment, they borrow that.
That's the key idea in
everything that follows.
What Coale and Hoover realized
is that if you have--
if a family has a lot of
children, if all the workers are
married and have a lot of
children,
all of their income goes for
food, clothing,
and shelter to support the
children.
They can't save any money.
If a country has no savings,
they don't have any money to
invest, they don't make any
economic progress.
This had a big political
effect, this theory.
It seems so simple and so
obvious but it--
apparently they had good
empirical support,
they studied Mexico and a
couple of other countries,
and showed that this really
seemed to be the case.
Well at that time the third
world was--the population
explosion was happening,
they were desperately poor,
and so there were two groups.
One, conservatives were at that
time worried about the Cold War.
America was locked in the Cold
War with communists and China,
Russia, but especially Russia
was our big enemy at the time.
We saw that all these
desperately poor countries,
the governments were not--their
current economic and political
systems were not giving them
what they want.
They were poor and getting
poorer as they perceived it,
and they were trying out all
kinds of different political
solutions,
some of which were leftist.
In America, there was a big
push by conservatives,
by the anti-communists,
to do something about the third
world to save them from
communism.
Meanwhile, the liberals were
less involved in this us versus
them kind of controversy,
but they saw all these poor
people in the world and wanted
to help all the poor people,
so they thought we should do
something about all these poor
people,
and the answer was economic
development.
Economic development was
universally approved in America
by everyone,
as either benevolent act by
someone who considered
themselves liberal or by a
self-serving anti-communist act
by someone who considered
himself a conservative.
Well, once the Coale/Hoover
paper came out and people
started realizing the--
what was considered to be the
obvious at that time,
it was very clear that family
planning programs had to be a
part of economic development.
That these countries just--with
these booming populations and
there were televisions full of
stories of India,
and how it was starving people
in India.
China was kind of closed to us
at that time,
but India was open,
but a desperate situation that
was in India and India had quite
leftist governments and was
India going to go communist,
etc.
Both sides of the--the whole
political spectrum believed in
economic aid to the developing
world and family planning aid.
It turns out that George Bush,
the senior,
the first George Bush
President, when he was a
congressman was one of the
sponsors of the very first
family planning bill,
not only for domestic family
planning but also the
international aid for family
planning.
This was not a debatable issue,
everybody agreed with it,
and it was really due to this
economic thesis by Coale and
Hoover.
You've read some of Ansley
Coale's stuff already.
Now, however,
the economists keep working,
the scholars keep going--what
they did is they looked cross
nationally and tried to figure
out,
is it really true that
population growth rate would
affect GDP,
the growth of gross domestic
product per capita,
it's basically per capita
income.
What did they find when they
got all the countries they could
find in the world?
Here's the growth rate and
here's per capita economic
growth.
What's the pattern?
Zero, there is no pattern here,
so it looks like that this--it
was meaningless.
That in fact the Coale/Hoover
hypothesis was wrong,
and however nice the theory
seemed, you just couldn't get
empirical evidence for it.
That was terribly important,
again a reversal,
now the Reagan Administration
comes in and on the basis of
information like that says,
economic population control is
no benefit to an economy's
growth,
and we, as conservatives,
are opposed to government
intervention in the private
lives of people,
so we're opposed to--we're not
going to give out the--
anywhere near the level of
family planning aid that we used
to.
The United States went from a
big leader in funding family
planning programs in the rest of
the world to trying to
discourage it.
We didn't drop to zero,
there were still programs that
we funded and they were very
good by AID,
but we were the main
discourager in the world,
we didn't like this whole idea.
What came up as--in opposition
to this,
and there was a big World
Congress about population and
development in Bucharest,
Romania at the time,
and the kind of data that came
out in this period is they--
they came out with the idea
that the way to get--
that it is good to have
fertility down for a lot of
reasons but the way to do it,
that the causality,
the Coale/Hoover causality is a
reduction in population growth
will lead to economic
development,
that the idea of the reverse
causality that an increase in
economic development will lead
to a decrease in fertility.
The slogan that came out of
this Bucharest meeting of all
the world leaders,
is that development was the
best contraceptive,
that if you wanted to lower
birth rates,
what you had to focus on was
economic development.
And that became the mantra for
the world and the developing
countries bought into that.
It was very interesting because
just at that time Romania,
the host of this meeting,
was having the most extreme
family planning program ever,
but in the opposite direction.
They, at that time,
it was a Soviet block country
that was doing poorly
economically,
their birth rate was very low,
their mechanism of birth
control was abortion;
4 out of 5 pregnancies were
terminated by abortions in
Romania.
For every one child-birth,
there were four abortions.
Romania, not for economic
reasons, but for nationalist
reasons, they wanted a bigger
stronger Romania so they clamped
down tremendously.
Abortion completely
de-legalized,
you couldn't get contraceptives
anymore,
and the end result was that the
birth rate temporarily fell but
then the women established
networks of illegal abortion and
gradually the birth rate rose
because they didn't have any
means,
but very rapidly within a year
or a two they established
illegal abortion networks and
the birth rate came down.
It never came down to its
original level and there's
actually a fairly big total
effect of their policy.
It was just the political
chicanery going on that here,
Ceausescu, who was running
Romania as a very strong
communist dictator,
was doing a very strong
pronatalist family policy,
but saying no,
the opposite won't work;
you have to go through economic
development.
Then people went to work on
that theory and here's the data,
that in this period of time,
these are the countries with
slow economic growth and their
population growth rate was about
2.7% and here's the ones with
fast economic growth rate and
their--
fast economic growth and
they're the same in terms of
population growth.
Here's your look some years
later and you have the same
story,
those with slow economic
growth, those with fast economic
growth have the same population
growth.
It is not true that development
itself acts as a contraceptive.
You look at it,
you spin the data,
the same data but differently,
you look at those countries
which have slow population
growth which are these,
and while it wasn't--or fast
population growth--
and you ask,
is that affecting GDP?
And you're not seeing a big
effect here in this time frame.
But you are seeing a big time
effect in this time frame.
Now something different is
going on,
here those countries with slow
population growth are increasing
economically,
those countries with fast
population growth are decreasing
economically.
The funny thing about this
graph, you say well it's the
same data, how can you come to
opposite conclusions?
It's not, the same data spun
differently.
This is the population growth
rate in 1965 to 1980 and then
the economic situation 25 years
later, 15 to 25 years later.
So something it looks like
from--This is not wildly
conclusive data,
but something about population
growth,
much later, has an effect on
your economic growth.
That's what has now been
figured out to be exactly the
really important relationship
between population growth and
economic development.
You've seen this graph many,
many times.
This is the standard
demographic transition where the
mortality rate,
the death rate falls first,
then after some delay the birth
rate falls and your population
growth rate is this period when
the birth rate is way above the
death rate.
Another aspect of that,
here's the same graph again up
here, is that if you ask what
does the share working look
like?
How many of these people are
working?
You have an idea called the
'dependency ratio' which is your
number of workers,
divided by your number of
children and your number of old
folks.
Well in developing countries
the medical care is bad so you
don't have--
you can almost ignore the old
folks for quite a period of
time,
so basically the workers
divided by the number of
children.
What happens during this period
is that as the fertility rate
falls what happens is you have a
population--
we've seen the population
pyramid for that with a number
of workers in the middle and
then many more children than
workers,
half again as many children as
so each worker has to
support--each person in working
age has to support 1.5 or 2
children of children's age.
Then you get this fantastic
fertility drop,
as we saw in places like China,
where, in ten years,
the fertility comes down,
and what happened?
This is the big population of
people at that age,
and there's no children coming
behind them.
Kids are born,
you have a very high
population,
kids are born,
then all of a sudden the
population stops having children
basically,
it drops tremendously,
but you still have all these
children born.
It takes 15,20 years for them
to get into working age,
so once you drop your fertility
you see no effect then because
you still have to support all
those children for the next
15,20 years.
It's only after delay of 15 to
20 years that you have this huge
number of people in working
ages,
very few children behind them,
and the ratio of workers to
dependents becomes very good.
This is the--the people inside
the snake.
That's a takeoff on another
'you are here' graph that I
showed you of the population
growth, anyway forget that.
Here is--you've seen this for
China but here's for all of East
Asia, this is the death rate and
the death rate is really
basically down by 1970.
I've showed you that for Egypt
and all around the world that
the mortality rate comes down
fast and then doesn't make an
awful lot of progress since
then.
This is people aging,
so this is where we are now,
about 2009, so this stuff is
all guessing about the future
but basically since 1970 the
death rate has been pretty
constant but the birth rate
comes down.
This big drop in 1970s,
again this is all of East Asia
but primarily what you're seeing
is China's big drop in the death
rate,
and so population growth
narrows, narrows down to almost
nothing.
Presumably in the near future
the death rate will climb above
the birth rate.
In looking at age structure,
this is kind of a complicated
graph, but they're very cute.
This is Sub-Saharan Africa as a
comparison, this is an opposite
situation.
Here this is like a piece of a
pyramid;
this is your age group.
Here you have very few old
people, here you have--
in 1950 this stripe is for the
year 1950 very few oldsters,
this is your working age
population in here say from 20
to 60 or whatever numbers you
want to put,
and there's more children in
any age group than any of them.
You've seen the population
pyramid like that.
Now as time goes on,
in a place like Sub-Saharan
Africa that does not go through
fertility transition is that
this shape of more children than
oldsters just continues 1975,
2000,2025.
You begin to see the--they hope
again--This is where we are now;
this is all guessing about the
future.
Up to now that shape of more
children down here--stays
unchanged and just the whole
population gets bigger,
you've seen that.
Now contrast that to East Asia,
which in 1950 had what looked
like Sub-Saharan Africa:
many more children than people
in working ages,
and again very few real old
folk.
Then time goes on but then you
start seeing funny things happen
where--
anyway up there follow
the--anywhere from 1975 and 2000
to the left and you see now the
number of children starts
dipping.
Up at the top it dips a lot and
the bulge of children becomes a
bulge in the working ages,
so you may have a lot of people
in working ages,
very few children,
no oldsters yet,
so you don't have anybody that
you have to support.
What happens is,
you calculate this dependency
ratio;
this is the number of working
age people to non-working age
and look what happens in East
Asia.
Here's the fertility decline,
as soon as ten years have
passed boom, boom,
boom the ratio gets to be
wonderful.
Again we are--at this level
we're somewhere near the peak,
the rest of this is guesswork
off to the right of that line.
The dependency ratio just gets
better and better for East Asia
and this has tremendous--this is
what has tremendous economic
consequences.
Here is the difference in the
economic growth per year
over--now this is a 25 year time
period we're not looking at a
single year.
It's tremendously bigger than a
place like Africa which has not
reduced its fertility.
We say this is based a lot on
savings and you'll have a
reading about this that you
won't like because it's somewhat
complicated economics,
but look at the savings rate in
East Asia.
It goes from 1955,
way before any of this,
14% to 35%, it goes up like a
factor of 2.5% or 3%;
tremendous saving.
Investment then,
since you're saving,
you can have an incredible
increase in investment which
builds up your country
economically.
Now the catch in this,
that savings equals investment,
you can also borrow money from
abroad and so that's what they
call the current account
balance,
how much money you can attract
from abroad to get developed.
We, in the West,
believe that it was Western
capital that went into China,
allowed them to build up and
did wonderful things.
But no, it was never huge,
this was a 4.8--
less than 5% was the
current--now that's a minus sign
in front of it,
that's what they're importing,
but very rapidly by 1980 they
start to be a net capital
exporter.
That these poor countries have
an excess of capital and they
now export to us,
so the development of China in
particular,
East Asia in general,
is not as you would think a
result of West--
infusion of Western capital.
I mean some of the early
special cases Hong Kong and so
forth clearly were,
but the main part of China,
they produced their own capital
because the sequence of
causality is fertility decline,
you wait 15,20 years all those
kids grow up,
there's none behind them,
they all become workers,
you start--you don't have
children to support,
you start saving,
those savings become
investments and you become one
of the economic miracles or one
of the tigers of the world.
Now until recently,
this theory is about 10 or 15
years old,
we're gradually coming to
understand this idea about the
economics,
and we start seeing something
special about Asia.
That, yes, this was important,
but also the culture of Asia,
the propensity to saving--the
savings--
when China was poor the savings
were not fabulous,
they are fabulous now,
but they weren't then,
that's a result of being rich.
It was thought there was
something special about East
Asia and China,
in particular,
something cultural,
and that when you did the
econometrics you had to have one
set of--
you could use the same amount,
you have one set of parameters
for Asia and a completely
different set for Africa,
and another set for Europe when
you don't consider the
demographic situation.
Once you put in the demographic
situation we now know that the
same model fits around the
world,
and it looks like that this
dependency burden is the key
thing.
One of the things that first
clued us into this was Ireland.
Ireland, which is a totally
different culture than China,
had this--it was totally
Catholic and they really
believed that they used
Catholicism as fighting--
as a mode of fighting the
British and so they had a very
high birth rate and they didn't
have legal contraception.
In 1980 the government
legalized contraception.
Here's the birth rate,
just takes a drive and then
after a little blip,
continues downward.
Again, it's the government
action of legalizing
contraception and the Irish
birth rate drops.
The death rate,
again, is slowly going down and
then sort of not really going
anywhere in this period and so
the population growth rate
decreases.
Again, this is the same thing,
you get the same effect that
Ireland's population looks like
China,
on a smaller scale,
it's not anywhere near as big
as China,
but again, you have an
underdeveloped country looking
thing.
There was a lot more children
than middle--than workers or old
people and then this continues
going up until you start getting
this decline.
Now in this modern period
currently there's a lot more
workers than there are either
children or old people so the
dependency burden looks real
good.
This is the graph of that.
The purple curve on the bottom
is Sub-Saharan Africa which
again up--just consider what's
up to the line because
everything else is guesswork.
Look, here the black is East
Asia and the green is Ireland,
looks very, very similar.
Guess what the result is,
here's where they legalized
birth control,
boom the economic growth rate
just booms right up ten or so
years later.
Now comparing--starting to
compare this to India,
here is China's growth per
capita.
In 1960, China was poorer than
India by a good bit,
this is per capita income,
the red is China,
the blue is India,
1960 they're poorer,
1970 they're poorer,
and 1980 they're poorer.
Wan, Xi, Shao,
the later, longer,
fewer, the fertility drop is in
this period and it starts going
and then China takes off and
exceeds India.
It's not due to the communist
government or a good government
because the communist revolution
is way out here and for a long
time it was not doing any better
than India,
but the main event that
happened then is the drop in
fertility.
This shows you the difference
in China's fertility and India's
fertility,
but here's this Chinese drop
starting in 1970s and India
slowly catching up but it's
taking its time about it.
This is the dependency burden,
here again, the ratio of
workers to non-workers really
improving in China,
not going anywhere particular
in India.
\When you compare it to
Sub-Saharan Africa--again so
we're comparing different parts
of the world to show you the
story--is the same.
This is the birth rate,
the black, and the death rate
so a huge and continuing
population;
growth rate again up to the
line, this is guesswork out here
and here is--
again you've seen this before,
this is China's--
East Asia's dependent ratio
workers to children.
This is Africa,
there is a huge difference
going on.
This is the situation--in
Sub-Saharan Africa the working
age population has gone up 2.6%.
Even if you can keep all those
people employed when the
dependent population goes up
2.7% you're not making any
progress.
Whereas in East Asia,
still a significant dependent
population,
they haven't stopped having
children altogether,
but the working age population
is growing half again as fast as
the dependent population,
that difference is what one,
makes you rich and two,
makes you be rich enough to
save and invest and develop your
country.
You've again seen this graph,
the difference between East
Asia and Africa.
That is the main idea that I
wanted to get for you.
I have to--by the way on your
schedule this lecture was
supposed to be given by David
Bloom,
who's a professor at Harvard,
and one of the guys who did a
lot of this work.
He wasn't able to come so I
used this--he came in the last
time I gave this class and I
used a lot of the slides that
are David Bloom's slides.
He's responsible for a fair
chunk of this work.
The end of this story is that,
again,
we talked about when--a long
time ago when I describe
Algeria's--
how much Algeria has gotten
their fertility down but their
population is still growing and
they haven't been able to take
advantage of a reduction in
fertility.
The same thing happens with
these dependency burden issues,
because you first have a lot
more children than workers,
than you stop having children,
and that bulge grows and you
get a lot more workers than
children.
Then those workers start to age
as the population decreases and
levels out,
so now you have the reverse
situation of a small number of
workers and a large number of
old people.
Always in dependency burden you
should add and old people and as
your fertility goes does,
your number of children goes
down, your number of oldsters
goes up,
so it's not as bad--it's not as
extreme a change as possible.
This would seem to be
called--this is called the
demographic dividend,
or the demographic bonus,
this phenomenon.
There's a time period when you
can make great economic progress
and then your people get old and
a lot of people believe that
Japan is in that situation right
now.
They have a very low birth rate
and the number of old people is
rising,
and whereas in the past,
old people cost almost nothing
because just a little bit of
food,
they didn't eat much,
but now with medical costs,
old people require lots of
money and in the past children
were expensive,
old people were cheap,
now its reversed.
The things that children use,
clothing comes from China,
it's very cheap,
food is comparatively cheap
around the world.
I mean forget the last half
year or something.
Children used to be
cheap--children used to be
expensive;
they're now getting cheaper,
old people are getting very
expensive.
Now the worry is that any
country that goes through a slow
demographic change and doesn't
arrange its economics and its
politics to employ the people,
because it doesn't do you any
good if you have a lot of
workers if they don't have any
jobs.
Latin America,
for instance,
which is kind of an in between
situation--was very
protectionist,
and nationalist,
and I can tell you a story.
Bolivia, next door to Peru,
and had so much conflict with
Peru that they didn't want to
form a common market with Peru
and they'd rather buy plastic
buckets from Brooklyn and rice
from China than they would to
trade with their next door
neighbor.
The story is that the
demographic situation seems to
be one of the major initiators
of these economic miracles that
have been happening around the
world but they can't do it by
themselves.
There has to be the economic
and political substructure to
employ these people,
to set them to work,
and then a country gets rich
and when it gets--
once it gets rich it gets the
capital that it can keep it
going.
That you now have enough money
to invest and keep going even
though you may have to spend a
lot on the old folks,
you may be rich enough to
generate the excess wealth to do
that.
Next time we'll talk about
economics and the family,
this has been macro economics,
how economics works on a whole
region wide thing,
but what its effect is on a
family.